أجنبية،
هذه إحدى زهوري الشخصية المفضلة
التي نزرعها هنا في الواقع
تسمى زهرة الكبوسين وتبدو
جميلة ورقيقة ولكن إذا تذوقتها فسوف
تحصل أولاً على
حلاوة الرحيق بشكل أساسي
وبعد ذلك سوف تحصل على هذا الجرجير الحار جدًا
الكعكة في الأساس لأنها
تحمل الكثير من القوة، دعنا نضع الأمر على
هذا النحو
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بك في منتجات ماريان الطازجة، أنا
ماريان وأود أن أخبركم
المزيد عن مزرعتنا
[موسيقى]
أوه،
لقد بدأت المزرعة رسميًا في  في عام 2018.
صادفنا فكرة الزهور الصالحة للأكل
لأنها شيء
حساس للغاية، لذلك إذا قمت باستيرادها
فإنها تتأثر بسرعة كبيرة.
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن استخدام الزهور الصالحة للأكل يشهد
بالتأكيد نموًا في المنطقة
مع تطور المشهد الغذائي في
بالطريقة والمعدل، كان هناك
الكثير من الطهاة الموهوبين بشكل لا يصدق
يجلبون مفاهيم جديدة أو يطورون
المفاهيم التي كان عليهم أن يحبوها
بمستويات عالية جدًا من الطعام الجيد، وكما تعلمون مع قدوم ميشلان
إلى هذا، كان هناك دافع
لذلك
لذا فإن المزرعة  تم إعداده
بمنطقة داخلية وخارجية على حد سواء مما
يسمح لنا بالنمو على أرض العام بشكل أساسي ولدينا
الآن أيضًا منطقة خارجية
لأننا أردنا تجربة ذلك،
وأعتقد أن لدينا
أكثر من 20 نوعًا من النباتات التي
نزرعها هنا، لذا  إنها مجموعة
متنوعة تمامًا وبعض المنتجات التي
قد تراها كثيرًا هي على سبيل المثال
الكمان أو زهور الثالوث التي تتميز
بألوان زاهية وهذا أحد
الأصناف الأحدث لدينا، لقد كان لديك دائمًا
حميض أرجواني كما نسميه  لدينا الآن
سلحفاة خضراء تبدو وكأنها
ورقة خضراء صغيرة بريئة ولكنها في
الواقع مليئة بما نسميه
حمض الأكساليك وهذا يمنحها طعمًا لاذعًا يشبه إلى حد كبير
هذه واحدة من تلك
النباتات حيث يمكنك استخدام كل من الورقة
و  الدقيق أيضًا، لذلك بالنسبة لي، يبدو الأمر
دائمًا وكأنني أمتلك
نسخة صحية من الحلوى الحلوة والحامضة،
لذا فهذه زهرة أخرى أحبها حقًا،
إنها زهرة الفاصوليا الأرجوانية
ولها هذا
اللون الأرجواني المشرق الجميل
وسوف تفاجئك النكهة إذا  أنت
تأكلها، فهي في الواقع حلوة تمامًا وتشبه
نوعًا ما من الفاصوليا الخفيفة، في
الغالب تكون المطاعم الفاخرة هي
التي تشجع على استخدام الزهور الصالحة للأكل
لأنه نعم لديك بعض الزهور
الملونة فقط ولكن الكثير منها يحمل أيضًا
الكثير  من النكهة، لذا فهي حقًا
مكون يجب أن تأخذه في
الاعتبار عند تطوير طبقك
مع ظهور Instagram
ويصبح الجانب المرئي للطبق أكثر
أهمية ويمكن أن تلعب الزهور الصالحة للأكل
دورًا مهمًا في ذلك أيضًا.